[Musique]
Laurent Berton, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Ben, succintement, je
dirais que je suis journaliste et
essayiste. Euh, j'ai écrit en 2013 La
France Orange mécanique, un livre sur
l'insécurité qui a pas mal fait de bruit
à l'époque.
Euh, j'ai écrit un livre sur le
conditionnement médiatique, la France
Big Brother, qui m'a valu d'être mis au
banc de la profession et des médias.
J'ai écrit Guerria, un livre sur
l'anticipation d'une possible guerre
civile en France. J'ai écrit très
récemment La France interdite, un livre
centré sur l'immigration
qui est au mon sens le sujet le plus
dangereux, le plus casse-gueule
aujourd'hui en France, hein. La France
interdite, c'est le titre du livre. Euh
évidemment, j'ai pas un accès médiatique
considérable pour en parler. Quand cet
accès a lieu, ça se résume à de
l'inquisition, à de l'intimidation.
Donc aujourd'hui, en France, on peut pas
débattre sereinement de ce qui touche à
l'insécurité, à l'immigration. au
conditionnement médiatique sans être
accusé de bah de ce qu'on sait de faire
le jeu de on sait qui on sait qui
euh l'extrême droite, le Front National
et cetera. Donc tout le débat public
aujourd'hui sur ces thématiques là est
entièrement piégé en fait et c'est ce
que j'ai voulu montrer dans ce livre en
plus de pour une fois apporter une vraie
pierre au débat, c'est-à-dire des
chiffres, des études précises sur la
question démographique, sur les
conséquences de l'immigration,
conséquences économiques, sociales,
culturell et cetera.
Donc voilà, en gros, j'ai essayé de de
faire le le tour du sujet de la manière
la plus complète possible, mais je
constate que le sujet n'accède pas ces
fameux grands médias, à part pour un
échange, enfin des échanges
spectaculaires en disant d'une part,
vous avez vous êtes un peu l'équivalent
de Méphistophéless, euh vous êtes
diabolique, vous tout ce que vous
incarnez est le mal. Donc on parle pas
de ce que vous avez fait de votre
travail mais simplement de vos
intentions présumées et on évite ce
faisant d'entrer dans le dans le vif du
sujet en fait. et on évite toujours ce
fameux débat. On parle en France depuis
très longtemps de l'immigration et de
ses conséquences, mais on en parle
jamais sur le fond. C'est toujours la le
postulat émotionnel, c'est-à-dire soit
on est contre et donc il faut tous les
rejeter à la mer et soit on est pour. Et
donc il constituent une richesse
formidable et il faut tous les
accueillir. Et entre les deux, il y a
pas de milieu, il y a pas d'argument
rationnel. Donc j'ai essayé de les de
les de les de les rassembler, de les
amener avec ce livre. En fait,
c'est quoi le milieu ? Le milieu, le
milieu, bah c'est justement une analyse
un peu dépassionnée de la question,
c'est-à-dire voilà factuellement
concrètement est-ce que la population de
la de la France change ? Euh si oui,
dans quelle proportion ? Est-ce que ça a
des conséquences qui sont positives sur
l'économie, sur la société, sur
Qu'est-ce que Qu'est-ce que vous
entendez par changement de population ?
la fameuse théorie du grand replacement,
des choses comme ça.
Voilà, on en parle beaucoup dans les
médias sous ce terme, c'est-à-dire la
théorie du grand remplacement qui
voudrait que les populations d'origine
européenne autochtone soient remplacé
petit à petit par immigrés d'origine
extraeuropéenne.
Euh dans les faits,
dire pourquoi dire autochtone ? Parce
que l'Europe est quand même un brassage,
non ? Bah, c'est-à-dire que depuis à peu
près 45000 ans euh les individus qui
vivent en Europe sont originaires de
d'eurasie, d'Europe et d'Asie. Et là,
les l'immigration qui concerne les
individus d'origine extraeuropéenne est
absolument inédite. N'a pas de n'a pas
de de précédents ou en tout cas des
précédents extrêmement minimes en tout
cas par rapport à ce qui ce qui a lieu
aujourd'hui. Donc c'est objectivement
c'est un phénomène totalement inédit par
son ampleur, par ses ses conséquences et
j'ai des chiffres pour étayer. Alors,
d'après euh donc les études que j'ai
collecté de l'INET, de l'INC, de des
j'ai j'ai je travaille uniquement sur
des études de démographe officiel pour
justement pas prêter le flanc à toutes
sortes d'accusations. Et j'arrive à la
conclusion qu'à peu près 18 % des
Français, enfin des habitants de la
France aujourd'hui sont d'origine
extraeuréenne.
mais que la pyramide des âges donne des
informations un peu complémentaires, à
savoir que les individus les plus âgés
en France aujourd'hui sont très
largement des autochtones, ce qu'on
appelle les Français de souche, les
natifs au carré, enfin voilà, il y a
quantité de désignation, chacun
retiendra celle qu'il préfère. Euh mais
quand on descend cette pyramide des
âges, on se rend compte que la
proportion d'individus originaire euh de
pays extraeurens, moyen-orientaux,
maghrébains, sub-sahariens devient de
plus en plus importante. Et quand on
arrive au nouveau né, on a à peu près 40
% des naissances aujourd'hui en France
qui sont d'origine extraeuréenne. Donc
il y a bien une évolution démographique
de la structure du peuple français et
même européen. On le constate partout.
Comment vous faites pour avoir des des
stats sur les les naissances en France ?
Alors, les naissances, il y a eu des
études qui ont été faites là-dessus par
l'INC et LINED en 2008. Donc, ça date un
petit peu mais déjà à cette époque-là,
ils admettait qu'à peu près 30 % des
naissances en France était d'origine
extraeuropéenne, de parents originaires
donc de pays extraeuropéens.
Euh il y a pas eu d'études qui ont été
menées plus récemment, mais on a euh ce
qu'on appelle la la drépanocytose, le
dépistage d'une maladie donc génétique
euh qui touche exclusivement des
populations issues euh donc d'Afrique
sub-saharienne, du bassin indien euh de
de donc en gros disons que les
populations qui sont dépistées
coïncident enfin ça coïncide à peu près
avec les populations extraeuropéennes
ce qui nous donne une sorte d'instrument
de mesure. En fait,
ça peut être la Martinique, la
Guadeloupe, les îles Caraïbes.
Oui, évidemment. Mais d'ailleurs, je
enfin j'explique dans le bouquin que il
y a voilà, il y a il y a comme ça par
exemple l'immigration asiatique,
chinoise, vietnamienne n'est pas
concerné par ce dépistage. Donc c'est
pas une valeur absolue. Mais l'un dans
l'autre quand on a accès à ces chiffres
qui sont très précis, qui sont plutôt
bien faits, ça donne un indicateur en
tout cas assez assez fiable
de la composition des naissances en
France. Euh cet indicateur d'ailleurs ne
sera plus reconduit puisque la haute
autorité de santé a décidé de s'en de ne
plus publier les résultats
justement parce qu'il montrait à mon
avis que cette tendance
euh
croissante de enfin de la la disons que
la part des naissances
extraeuropéennes devenait de plus en
plus importante et que justement ça
alimentait ça mettait ça apportait de
l'eau au moulin de Renault Camu sa
théorie du remplacement et cetera
et qu'effectivement la structure de la
population française changeait et qu'il
est pour ces je pense pour les hautes
autorités de santé le gouvernement, il
est dangereux d'en parler parce qu'ils
savent très bien que les Français ça les
inquiète objectivement parce que en
France on nous explique
permet de dire que ça les inquiète
en France on nous explique depuis très
longtemps que la démographie la natalité
française se porte extrêmement bien par
rapport à la natalité européenne que on
n'est pas loin des deux enfants par
femme donc que tout va très bien les
générations sont renouvelées
Sauf que justement quand on fait ce
détail, quand on prend en compte pas
seulement la natalité des immigrés, mais
aussi des descendants d'immigrés, on se
rend compte que la natalité Oui, des les
descendants d'immigrés sont français
mais on se rend compte que la natalité
des autochtones, c'est-à-dire des
populations originaires d'Europe, est
extrêmement basse, à peu près 1,2 1,4
enfants par femme en Italie, en
Allemagne, en France et que ce déficit
démographique est palié par cette
immigration l'ONU hein, c'est l'ONU qui
a employé ce terme l'immigration de
remplacement pour dire ces individus ne
le stock de consommateur n'est pas
renouvelé donc il faut les remplacer
donc il faut faire venir cette
immigration
tant pis enfin si elle n'est pas de la
même culture s'il y a un différentiel
culturel important si son niveau de
qualification ne correspond pas à celui
de l'occance le but du jeu est d'avoir
de maintenir le nombre de consommateurs
en gros parce que comme ça le gâteau
économique le produit intérieur brut
reste à peu près constant.
Donc c'est c'est un c'est un c'est un
choix de leur part, pourquoi pas ? Sauf
qu'il partent du postulat que ce ce cet
état de fait ne va pas avoir de
conséquences fâcheuses pour la société
française. Et là on arrive à un discours
qui est à mon avis parfaitement
idéologique et qui refuse justement
d'appréhender la globalité des
conséquences de l'immigration. Sur le
plan économique, on nous explique
toujours, c'est une chance, c'est une
richesse. rapporte ça rapporte peut-être
à ceux qui sont tout en haut de la
pyramide économique, les patrons, les
individus très hautement qualifiés, mais
à ceux qui sont en bas, c'est-à-dire les
travailleurs moyens, les les les
individus peu qualifiés, ils subissent
objectivement la concurrence de
l'immigration en terme d'emploi, en
terme de salaire et il transfèrent une
partie de leur du fruit de leurs
efforts, de leur productivité sous forme
de la fiscalité vers des individus comme
ils sont très fortement sous-qualifiés
par rapport par rapport à la moyenne de
l'OCDE, ils sont davantage bénéficiaires
des aides sociales. Ils ont un taux
d'emploi qui est nettement plus faible
que le taux d'emploi
Ah oui, ben le bouquin alors pour le
coup regorge de sources euh justement
comme je le dis exclusivement des
sources officielles ou publiées dans des
revues scientifiques de premier plan
c'est l'inide essentiellement parce que
toutes les tous les chiffres existent.
C'est ça en France en général on me dit
mais on nous cache tout, on dit rien.
Euh les démographes font leur boulot. Le
problème c'est que ce leur conclusion
n'arrive pas jusqu'aux écrans. Le
démographe à la télévision vous explique
non l'immigration ne fait pas changer la
France puisque l'immigration elle est
stable depuis Clovis parce que il y a
toujours 8 % d'immigrés en France. Les
immigrés nés à l'étranger mais on parle
pas des descendants d'immigrés
évidemment. Oui, mais le il y a une
hypocrisie fondamentale là-dedans parce
que le type le français moyen qui
regarde la qui se promène dans la rue ou
qui voit les états civils ou les photos
de classe et cetera, lui il dit "Mais
moi j'ai l'impression que la population
de la France évolue et c'est lui
mentir."
évolue comment ? en couleur, en taille,
en couleur, en couleur. Elle évolue.
Enfin, c'est son cette fameuse diversité
visible dont on dit qu'elle est pas
assez représenté dans les médias et
cetera et qu'on lit intrinsèquement à
une richesse, c'est-à-dire une forme de
supériorité qui est basée uniquement
justement sur cette apparence et cette
couleur, une forme de racisme inversé.
En fait, la diversité est une richesse.
Ça veut clairement dire bah si vous êtes
de la bonne couleur, vous avez une sorte
de plusvalue en fait. que non pas les
blancs quel qu'ils soient, d'où qu'ils
viennent, quel que soit leur leur niveau
leur niveau de vie, leur apport culturel
et cetera. Donc moi, je considère que
c'est un problème de de de regarder les
choses à travers ce prisme.
Il y a toujours beaucoup de
discrimination à l'embauche pour les
gens qui ne sont pas de la bonne couleur
aussi, non ?
Alors, ça c'est justement c'est un des
thèmes assez importants dans ce livre.
Je montre que pour la discrimination, on
se base sur une équivalence présumée des
compétences
à diplômes égaux. Par exemple, le l'OCDE
a fait des calculs là-dessus,
c'est-à-dire qu'un immigré niveau
licence et un autochtone
de souche qui avait un niveau licence
aussi, on s'est l'OCDE s'est rendu
compte que il y avait 3 années d'écart
de compétence entre les deux.
C'est-à-dire que la licence d'un
immigré, elle ne correspond pas du tout
au niveau de compétence d'une licence
française. Donc évidemment, à partir de
là, vous allez trouver des
discriminations parce que si vous pensez
que les deux niveaux sont égaux et donc
évidemment l'immigré, son taux d'accès à
l'emploi ou son salaire et cetera, enfin
tout est plus faible. Sauf que quand on
se base sur le niveau d'aptitude
stricte, là on se rend compte que non
seulement l'immigré n'est pas
désavantagé, mais que même plus on va
vers les les les professions qui sont
valorisées socialement, qui sont
fortement payées, plus il est même
avantagé. Ça veut dire que notre
société, je pense, a intériorisé ce
discours, la diversité est une richesse
et cetera. Euh il faut agir de manière
antiraciste, il faut même donner des
gages euh qu'on est qu'on pense bien,
qu'on est du bon côté du de ce monde. Et
plus on va aller vers les métiers euh
bien payés dans les grandes entreprises,
dans les grands groupes, plus on va
avoir cette espèce de discrimination.
C'est même pas un mot d'ordre,
c'est-à-dire que les RH ou les les
recruteurs ou les les responsables
poussent en avant la diversité comme une
sorte de produit marketing. Les partis
politiques aussi le font. Sarkozy se
cachait pas de il me faut un noir à mon
meeting à côté de moi pour la photo, ce
serait très bien et une noire, ce serait
encore mieux. Donc c'est une manière
très cynique encore une fois d'utiliser
des individus euh au profit moral
exclusif.
Qui dit Emmanuel Vals, il dit il faut un
euh Sarkozy disait ça.
Ouais mais et Emmanuel Vass, il dit quoi
? Il dit il faut un blanco ou un truc
comme ça ? Non.
Oui, il voulait dans dans sa ville, il
estimait que sa ville manquait un peu de
diversité. C'est-à-dire que bon, ça
c'est la problématique des des
communautaires, c'est-à-dire
qu'évidemment euh vous avez de part
cette immigration massive. On parle de
millions d'individus, des gens qui se
regroupent et qui vivent entre eux parce
que ils n'ont plus ces individus là de
par leur niveau de qualification
devraient correspondre à des
travailleurs de l'industrie d'une
industrie qui n'existe plus. Donc ces
individus-là n'ont pas euh d'offre
objectives de travail qui correspondent
à leur niveau de qualification et en
plus il bénéficient assez largement
d'aide social qui sont 10 à 20 fois
supérieur au salaire des pays d'origine.
Les sources les sources.
Oh bah les sources c'est facile de
vérifier. Vous prenez le niveau du RSA,
vous allez voir le le salaire des pays
d'Afrique sub-saharienne et vous
comprendrez que ça vaut largement le il
vaut mieux être ici et ne pas travailler
ou travailler au noir dans un boulot
extrêmement ingrat et mal payé que
travailler même pour un un dans un
boulot plutôt prestigieux en Afrique
sub-saharienne. Ça, ce sont des
réalités. Et donc, on peut pas du tout
en vouloir aux individus. C'est normal.
Enfin, c'est un calcul. Voilà, chacun
est libre de faire ce qu'il veut. Si les
individus veulent venir ici pour
profiter de ça, euh c'est voilà, c'est
leur problème ou fuir la guerre, non ?
Fui la guerre aussi,
fu la guerre économique.
Après, le problème, c'est que les
prétextes ne manqueront jamais. C'est ce
que j'expliquer. Quelqu prétextes sont
utilisés ? Les prétextes à l'immigration
sont innombrables en fait, que ce soit
de déplacement économique écologique
parce qu'on parle du réchauffement
climatique aujourd'hui, le professeur
Stephen Smith qui est un africaniste a
montré que d'ici 30 à 40 ans, compte
tenu de la démographie africaine
sub-saharienne en particulier, on aurait
des dizaines de millions d'immigrés qui
viendraient en France, quel que soit
d'ailleurs nos nos dizaines de millions,
des dizaines de millions. Absolument.
Euh aujourd'hui en Afrique sub-sène, il
y a 1,3 milliards d'habitants, il y en
aura 4 milliards en 2100. euh quoi qu'il
se passe, quelses que soient les
épidémies, les guerres et cetera, la
fourchette basse de l'ONU, c'est c'est 4
milliards d'habitants. On peut pas, si
vous voulez, il y a aucune croissance
euh il y a aucun développement euh ni en
terme d'infrastructure ou d'alimentation
et cetera qui peut suivre une telle
croissance démographique. Donc
mécaniquement, beaucoup d'individus très
jeunes et sans emploi vont force
forcément aller chercher ailleurs de
quoi vivre, de quoi survivre. C'est
parfaitement humain. Il y aura des
quantités de de raisons à cela que vous
l'avez dit, les guerres, les les
épidémies, une vie meilleure, enfin tout
ce qu'on veut. Mais la vraie enfin la
seule question qu'on doit se poser nous,
c'est est-ce que on peut accueillir des
dizaines de millions d'individus dans
notre pays et en et en assumer les
conséquences où est-ce qu'on décide de
ne pas le faire ? Donc en fait, moi
c'est l'alternative que je pose, c'est
qu'à un moment donné la France est un
pays souverain. Les citoyens français
exprime un rejet assez massif de
l'immigration dans les enquêtes
d'opinion. Euh 75 % des Français euh je
crois aux dernières nouvelles estimaient
que il y avait trop d'immigrés en France
sans les termes du sondage. Qui
le sondage ? Alors là ça doit être je
crois que c'est au dos que ça mais il
faut vérifier combien de personnes
si vous voulez vous avez des sondages
assez permanents sur ce sujet et très
largement les Français montrent et en
plus 75 % plus tous ceux qui n'ont pas
osé le dire que l'immigration pour eux
était un problème. On n'écoute pas ces
inquiétudes là. On criminalise même ses
inquiétudes. C'est-à-dire qu'en gros le
français qui pense ça
qui criminalise ça,
il est bon le système médiatique et
politique très largement. Euh on vous
explique à longueur de enfin j'en ai
fait l'expérience moi-même si vous la
voix de de cette majorité qui qui est
vraiment une voix enfin majorité
anti-immigration n'est pas audible dans
ces grands médias aujourd'hui. Par qui
dans les grands médias qui représente
cette majorité énorme ? Là, il y a un
holdup démocratique parfait.
C'est-à-dire que cette caste médiatique
et journalistique a une idée qui est
diamétralement posée. L'idée
l'immigration est une richesse, une
chance pour la France et cetera
est martelé en permanence par ces grands
médias. Vous pouvez peut-être compter à
peu près cinq individus comme l'a fait
le monde, Zemour, Polonie et cetera.
Individus qui sont plus ou moins
hostiles à l'immigration et qu'ils le
disent dans ces grands médias. Mais dans
l'ensemble, c'est ces médias ne sont
absolument pas représentatifs de la
population française.
Et qui d'autre dans les cinq ?
Je pense que vous avez Charlotte
Dornella euh
qui qui passe chez Pascal pro assez
régulièrement.
C'est ça. Voilà, vous voyez, je j'arrive
plus à je peux moi j'en trouve pas
d'autres mais le monde l'a fait. Le
monde a fait une enquête en nous
expliquant que c'était la menace de la
peste brune qui revenait et cetera. Il
faut faire attention au ventre toujours
fécond de la bâtiment. Euh comme
d'habitude, c'est tout repose sur cette
espèce de de de chantage au racisme. Ça
veut dire que si vous n'avez pas une
position qui est compatible avec ce
progressisme de l'accueil de l'autre, de
l'enrichissement et cetera, et bien vous
êtes vous êtes l'extrême droite. Pour
moi, l'immigration n'a pas être un sujet
politique. L'immigration ou
l'insécurité, n'importe qui peut avoir
une position qui lui est propre. Euh un
type de gauche qui se fait poignarder
euh je vois pas en quoi il le il le il
le vivrait mieux qu'un type de droite.
Ça doit pas être des sujets politiques.
Mais on les a politisé, on a expliqué
que tous ceux qui avaient une position
euh différente sur l'insécurité de
l'immigration étaient l'extrême droite.
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça que Marine Le
Pen est qualifiée de femmes politiques
d'extrême droite. Parce qu'à mon sens,
économiquement à l'état gauche,
socialement à l'état gauche, qu'est-ce
qui est là d'extrême droite sinon ?
Cette position iconoclaste sur
l'insécurité et l'immigration. C'est la
seule raison et ça permet justement
d'empêcher complètement un débat
rationnel parce que si vous êtes
l'extrême droite, vous êtes le diable.
C'est quoi un débat rationnel ?
Un débat rationnel, c'est-à-dire comme
je je vous le fais, je vous amène des
chiffres, des sources et on en discute.
Et on peut parler objectivement, évaluer
les conséquences complètes, sans se
crier dessus, sans s'insulter, sans
entrer dans cet espace de spectacle
médiatique qui finalement ne débouge
jamais sur rien de concret.
Et c'est un problème grave parce que
couper comme ça une majorité des
citoyens de leur représentation
médiatique et même universitaire
et même politique participe d'une forme
de partition du pays en fait entre cette
élite qui est complètement déconnectée
qui est sur une planète qui lui permet
d'échapper à tous les désagréments du
vivre ensemble et et à la réalité
finalement et cette immigration ce
quotidien du vivre ensemble est
différemment perçu si on fait partie des
classes supérieures évidemment où là
pour le coup la seule diversité qu'on
connaît et ben soit elle passe le balai
dans les coins discrètement ou soit elle
est du même niveau social donc elle a
les mêmes opinions donc évidemment il y
a pas de problème mais si vous descendez
au bas de l'échelle de la société et
bien là la diversité l'enrichissement il
est vécu très différemment et tant qu'on
fera pas l'effort de comprendre ça de
descendre un petit peu de de son nuage
tant que les médias plutôt que de média,
ça veut dire intermédiaire. Tant qu'ils
ne feront plus ce rôle de passerelle de
l'information réelle entre le peuple et
les faits, tant qu'ils feront cette
barrière, je pense que on va vers une
enfin vers des des des ennuis très
sérieux.
On va on va revenir sur ces ennuis très
sérieux que vous vous anticipez.
Euh quel a été votre
attitude de journaliste d'investigation
pour aller voir ce qui se passe dans la
le bas de la pyramide dans la la France
d'en bas ? Vous avez fait quoi pour
sonder prendre la température, voir ce
qui se passe ?
Bah moi déjà je viens de la France d'en
bas et donc j'ai moins de j'ai moins de
problèmes avec ça. C'est plutôt l'autre
France que je connais moins bien, que
j'ai appris à connaître justement à
l'école de journalisme et cetera. Euh et
donc j'ai tout de suite vu cette
rupture, c'est-à-dire que moi, la France
Orange Mécanique, les médias l'ont
qualifié de livres scandaleux et cetera,
excessif, enfin tout ce qu'on veut.
Pourquoi ?
Et euh les les les types que je j'ai
rencontré dans les bistro ou les
victimes de de criminalité ou les
citoyens de base m'ont dit "Mais c'est
c'est extrêmement modéré. Enfin, vous
êtes très loin de la réalité de ce qu'on
vit."
Vous az rencontré dans quel cadre ?
Alors pour la France Orange mécanique,
je les ai rencontré malheureusement.
Malheureusement, il y a des discussions
dans les tribunaux
dans les commissariats au quotidien. Au
quotidien quand j'étais fait diversier,
donc j'ai rencontré pas mal de victimes.
Diversier, ça veut dire les
donc les les journalistes qui écrivent
sur les faits d'hiver,
sur les les chats écrasés,
les chats, voilà, les chiens écrasés,
enfin les toutes les affaires
réjouissantes euh qui qui qui font
d'ailleurs une bonne partie des ventes
des presses locales, hein, parce que
c'est ça qui attire l'œil.
Euh donc j'ai pu rencontrer beaucoup de
victimes, de professionnels de la
sécurité, des policiers, des magistrats
et cetera. Et j'ai compris très vite
qu'il y avait ce problème de décalage
énorme notamment avec les policiers. Les
policiers aujourd'hui euh sont dans un
état de de tension qu'il est vraiment
difficile d'imaginer.
Est-ce que vous avez fait le travail
inverse ?
Le travail inverse
d'aller voir la France de l'immigration,
la France des quartiers. Absolument.
Absolum. Si je vous prends par la main
et qu'on va dans le fin fond du 93, vous
allez sortir comment ?
Oh bah écoutez, je ça dépend où on va.
Je me sentirai comme tout le monde
pour pourquoi pas. Moi je enfin je l'ai
déjà fait et il y a pas de problème.
Non, moi j'ai le terrain ne me fait pas
peur. Justement, le fait ne me fait pas
peur. Et je précise bien d'ailleurs
c'est important de de le dire, c'est que
évidemment un type non averti qui va
lire mes constats
mais que où il veut en venir et cetera.
Est-ce qu'il est pas en train
d'amalgamer, stigmatiser ? machin tout
ça, c'est pas du tout ce que je dis ce
fameux pas d'amalgame
mais c'est pas du tout ce que je dis
mais je dis que si on ne prend pas en
compte euh la comment dire la la
surreprésentation dans la criminalité de
certaines franges issues de
l'immigration si on s'interdit de faire
des constats comme ça là vraiment parce
que on on se prive de réalité non
seulement ça veut dire qu'on prend les
les citoyens pour des abrutis dangereux
fanatiqu
mais en plus on On on ne peut résoudre
aucun problème si on se prive d'une
partie de l'équation. C'est
la proportion la proportion de de des
crimes et délits selon vous ou selon vos
stats, c'est c'est ça représente quoi ?
C'est
à peu près 2 tiers des crimes et délits
commis en France sont sont commis par
des individus issus de l'immigration à
peu près.
Si vous allez dans une prison
aujourd'hui, vous pouvez faire le ratio
et vous allez vous arriverez à peu près
à 75 à 80 % d'individus issus de
l'immigration. Comment on fait ? Comment
on fait pour
savoir qu'ils sont ici l'immigration
s'ils sont nés sur le sol français ?
Ah bah, il suffit de leur demander. Il y
a il y a des enquêtes qui sont faites
là-dessus par des sociologues. On
demande aux individus votre origine,
d'où vous venez, est-ce que vous êtes
descendant d'immigrés et cetera et les
gens répondent, il y a pas de problème.
On peut avoir des des des trucs très
précis là-dessus. Non, là-dessus, les je
encore une fois les enquêtes, les
universitaires font leur boulot. Mais le
problème c'est qu'une fois qu'un
universitaire va faire une enquête comme
ça, s'il passe à la télé euh quelle que
soit sa réputation par ailleurs, on le
traitera de enfin on l'accusera de faire
le jeu de machin. On lui dira que c'est
pas le bon moment parce que c'est jamais
le bon moment pour parler de
l'immigration et de l'insécurité et il
sera enfin sa réputation sera vraiment
attaquée. Il y a eu par exemple le Cad
Granche qui avait fait ça récemment, qui
avait parlé de l'insécurité,
qui avait lié une certaine forme de
délinquence à la culture
de certains immigrés et ça lui avait
coûté très cher. Et ce type est
objectivement fait un travail sérieux,
très sourcé, impeccable. Mais ce qu'il
dit, c'est pas progressiste, ça fait pas
le jeu de la mondialisation heureuse, du
vivre ensemble et cetera. Donc il ne
devait pas le dire et il ferait mieux de
se concentrer sur la sexualité des
algues marines et je sais pas quoi. En
tout cas ne pas parler de ça et ça c'est
systématique. Donc il faut bien
comprendre que le sociologue qui va
faire son enquête euh
non s'il en parle ne sera même pas
médiatisé et s'il est médiatisé sera
comparé de de de complice du mal et
cetera. Donc il y a une forme
d'autocensure assez générale dans le
milieu universitaire, dans le milieu
médiatique parce que moi j'ai j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de journalistes et de
sociologues et qui partagent mes
constats.
Qui
je pas donner de nom parce que je
protège mes sources mais il y a des
journalistes très connus qui sont
exactement
qui font les mêmes constats que moi, qui
me disent que tu fais c'est génial et
cetera mais tu sais que je peux pas en
parler. Bon très bien. Et parce que tous
ces gens se font peur en fait. Il y a il
y a pas tant de militants que ça. Il y
en a des militants, c'est-à-dire les
types Emeric Caron machin qui vont
désigner d'être d'être un d'être un truc
diabolique et cetera. Il y en a
certains, mais tous les autres ils sont
victimes. C'est-à-dire qu'ils suivent et
ils ont peur et donc ils se taisent et
ils peuvent pas exprimer des opinions,
même si elles sont juste compatibles
avec la très large majorité de la
population. Euh Jean-Pierre Perna par
exemple avait s'était amusé lors on
connait on connait votre anecdote
lors d'un JT avait dit voilà euh les la
les les migrants sont accueillis pas les
SDF euh voilà sujet suivant et ça lui
avait coûté cher et il sait très bien
que s'il y a récidive tout Jean-Pierre
Perna qu'il est il perd sa place. Donc
aujourd'hui euh plus on a à perdre en
fait dans ce système, plus on est obligé
de se conformer à l'idéologie dominante.
Plus on monte haut, plus on a peur de
tomber de
Oui, c'est la métaphore de l'échelle.
Voilà, si vous êtes très haut, vous vous
faites très mal. Si vous êtes en bas, on
s'en fout. Personne vous écoute. Vous
criez dans le bar d'à côté et pas de
problème, vous pouvez y aller. Vous
n'avez rien à perdre.
Vous parlez souvent de de monsieur
Moyen.
C'est quoi monsieur Moyen ?
Monsieur Moyen,
c'est Oui, voilà. C'est le le le type de
base, c'est l'homme normal, celui qui
regarde la télé 4 heur par jour, qui
écoute la radio 2h par jour et qui n'a
pas forcément une grande culture sur le
milieu médiatique, qui comprend pas bien
toutes les ramifications machin
intellectuel qui se qui suit un peu le
mouvement. Euh et lui il est il est il
est il est objectivement il a envie de
de dire que cette immigration ça
l'inquiète mais il ne le fait pas parce
que il sait que dans un repas de famille
ou dans la rue ou avec ses collègues, il
peut se faire laté par un clone d'Émeric
Caron qui va lui dire "Vous êtes raciste
et cetera." Et ça ça le terrorise. Et il
a raison parce queon a tous quelque
chose à perdre et notre situation
sociale est très importante. Notre plus
grande peur de mammifère et d'être exclu
de notre groupe, l'ostracisme.
Euh donc ben on a tendance à émettre des
opinions modérées et conformes surtout
sur des sujets aussi casse-gu
l'immigration.
Du sol, on en fait quoi ?
Le droit du sol. Al moi je suis pas
politicien. Je veux pas vous faire la
recette miracle de tout ce qu'il
faudrait faire. Moi je je je me mets
juste le doigt où ça fait où ça merde où
ça fait mal.
Le droit du sol évidemment euh à mon
sens participe pas mal du problème parce
que on y euh le substrat de la société
euh le peuple en fait et on en gros on
nous explique que c'est pas ça qui
compte, c'est juste la motivation des
individus. Ça c'est sur le papier, c'est
une pourquoi pas. Moi je suis d'accord.
Je pense que des individus qui ont envie
d'être français peuvent faire
d'excellents français. font souvent des
Français d'ailleurs bien plus patriotes
euh et travailleurs que les Français
autochtones eux-mêmes. Euh à
partir de combien de générations on
vient autochtone pour vous ?
Je sais pas. Moi je suis personne pour
dire ça. C'est pas à moi de dire en fait
lui c'est un bon français machin c'est
je suis pas je suis rien. Moi je suis
une voix sur 66 millions. Donc j'ai
sûrement pas à dire ça. Je suis
peut-être un très mauvais français
d'ailleurs.
Sur les 66 millions, il y en a combien
qui sont pas de chez nous comme vous
dites ? Ah non, mais enfin ça c'est leur
problème. C'est-à-dire que bah quand
vous allez dans certaines zones certains
pans du territoire français, vous
constatez objectivement bah on l'a dit
tout à l'heure par exemple si on fait le
tour de la scène Saint-Denis, il y a pas
mal d'individus que vous allez croiser
et que objectivement il est difficile de
les relier à la culture française, à
l'histoire française, à un ardent désir
d'intégration,
d'apprendre la langue, de trouver un
travail et cetera, de d'aller dans le
sens de l'intérêt général plutôt que
dans le sens de l'intérêt communautaire.
Mais c'est humain de faire ça, c'est ce
que j'explique dans le bouquin. Je ces
gens-là enfin c'est il y a il y a pas de
critique sur le fait de de d'exploiter
un système qui s'offre à eux. C'est qui
qu'il soit d'ailleurs enfin le système
social, le système criminel et cetera.
Tout peut s'expliquer en fait. Moi je
cherche à comprendre les individus. Je
je fais pas de jugement, je suis pas
Dieu, je suis pas un juge. Mais seul
simplement si on se place dans le dans
la peau de monsieur moyen dans le sens
de l'intérêt général, c'est-à-dire
l'idée que la société est une somme
d'individus qui agissent sous une forme
d'altruisme réciproque. C'est-à-dire je
reçois, je donne et cetera et tout le
monde s'en trouve enrichi. Et s'il
constate qu'il y a ces compétitions
communautaires, qu'il y a du
clientélisme des élus locaux, euh que
finalement certains ne jouent pas le
jeu, que lui travaille beaucoup et euh
voit une grosse partie du fruit de ses
revenus ponctionner pour alimenter de
telles compétitions intercommunautaires,
évidemment, lui, il va arrêter de jouer
le jeu aussi. Il va commencer à tricher.
Il y a une forme de repli sur soi des
individus. Ça c'est pour moi une des
conséquences fondamentales de
l'immigration, c'est cet effondrement du
capital social, ce qu'on appelle du
capital social. le lien social justement
cette forme de réciprocité de confiance
mutuelle qui unit les citoyens d'une
société entre eux et on constate
objectivement on a constaté aux
États-Unis d'abord et un peu partout en
Europe ensuite que ce capital social
s'effondrait
en préparant l'interview euh je me suis
souvent rendu compte que il y avait que
des médias d'extrême droite ou des
villes d'extrême droite ou des villes à
connotation d'extrême droite qui vous
recevaient h
est-ce qu'il y a des gens de gauche qui
ont essayé de vous contacter de vous
faire faire des conférences.
Est-ce que Est-ce que c'est normal qu'il
y ait que des gens d'extrême droite qui
s'intéressent à ce que vous faites ?
Ah, je je pense pas du tout qu'il y a
que des gens d'extrême droite qui
s'intéressent à ce que je fais. Par
contre, ceux qui vont évidemment
m'inviter ou os me donner la parole ou
paraître avec moi et cetera, comme je
suis moi-même comme j'ai moi-même été
catalogué justement par cette ce mes
charmants collègues euh
enquête de méiapart est vrai ou pas sur
le fait que vous étiez blogueur
d'extrême droite caché sur un pseudo
absolument pas absolument pas mais
vous êtes vous êtes allé au procès ou
pas vous avez
Non non non non j'ai j'ai arrêté j'ai
arrêté toutes mes actions judiciair
pourquoi
euh parce que il y avait plusieurs
plusieurs ordres de raison dans des
raisons personnelles
sur une volonté de un peu libertarienne
de ne plus entraver la parole de qui que
ce soit en fait. Et comme j'ai connu,
j'ai vu un peu ce qu'était le
fonctionnement judiciaire de
l'intérieur, j'ai préféré assez
radicalement m'en éloigner. Et ça
concerne pas que Miaapart, c'était
toutes mes affaires en cours qui ont été
arrêtées en même temps parce que je sais
très bien que ça mène à bien plus
d'ennui que qu'autre chose. Mais cette
enquête enfin là était absolument
erronée. Je suis désolé pour eux mais
toute façon le enfin ils avaient même
pas besoin de ça. De toute façon, ils
sont ils étaient d'accord dès le début
pour dire que j'étais une sorte de de
résurgence des heures les plus sombres.
Et comme tout le monde l'a martelé et
que les uniques sources qui apparaissent
quand on essaie de se renseigner sur
moi, sur Google, Wikipédia et cetera
sont des sources qui émanent de ces
médias officiels. Donc des gens qui me
considèrent comme une sorte de traître
puisque moi j'ai je n'ai pas voulu faire
ma carrière dans ce milieulà parce que
j'ai voulu dire certaines vérités qui ne
permettaient pas de conserver un poste
dans ce milieu-là. Donc je suis une
sorte, je sais pas, de dissident ou de
mouton noir et je donc je suis mis à
l'écart. Je suis catalogué extrémiste de
droite, ce qui n'est absolument enfin
qui ne repose sur rien. Sinon, je suis
pas d'accord avec eux.
Vous votez quoi ? Moi, je vote selon mon
âme et conscience dans l'isoloir, dans
le secret absolu de de voilà, je ne dis
pas pour qui je vote, mais j'ai pas
d'acquintance du tout politique. Ça
c'est important de le préciser. Enfin,
mon travail est ultra indépendant mais
évidemment c'est une manière de
m'isoler, de dire "Regardez, il est allé
donner une conférence avec tel individu
qui lui-même est lié à tel tel groupe et
cetera." Donc vous voyez, c'est
l'extrême droite. Sauf que si on répète
ça tout le temps, évidemment le personne
ne va oser vous inviter. Moi alors là si
Annie Dalgo m'invite à un séminaire
demain, j'y vais.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi on vous invite nous
?
Bah on m'invite parce que je sais pas
pourquoi nous on vous a invité. Ah vous
alors ça ça ça ne tient qu'à votre il y
a que vous qui pouvez répondre à cette
cette question intéressante.
Ça ça vous a surpris
honnêtement un peu un peu parce que
justement pour ces raisons-là parce que
je me je j'ai tellement l'habitude si
vous voulez même les types qu'on décrit
comme potentiellement proche tu vas voir
Polonie elle va parler de toi Zemour
Renolo, ils vont parler de toi Éric
Brunet il va t'inviter Hardisson va
t'inviter. Bah non. Donc oui, ça me
surprend parce que j'ai bien plus
l'habitude des portes qui claquent que
des portes qui s'ouvrent.
Vous connaissez notre chaîne YouTube ?
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez vu chez nous ?
J'ai vu alors je me souviens plus du nom
malheureusement de l'intervenant. Euh
c'était une vidéo, enfin vraiment la
première vidéo qui m'a marqué, c'était
une vidéo une thématique écologique sur
euh
voilà ça c'est c'est cette ce thème
m'intéresse beaucoup et j'avais trouvé
justement que le format était très
intéressant de ce jeune que je
malheureusement je n'ai pas vu par
ailleurs sur nos chez nos grands médias
et je pense pas qu'il y passe beaucoup.
Je pense qu'il est sûrement trop
intelligent pour ça. Et donc voilà.
Enfin, moi j'aime bien ce format, le le
l'idée de donner la parole à tout le
monde d'où qu'ils viennent justement
sans avoir ces espèces de de tampon
idéologique fourni en option. C'est ça
le problème aujourd'hui de la
télévision, c'est qu'elle est tellement
archimorale que c'est Disney. Vous avez
les méchants, vous avez les gentils. Euh
le téléspectateur n'admet pas en fait
d'avoir quelqu'un qui n'est pas
étiquetable, qu'on peut pas plier dans
sa case, qui n'est qui ne joue pas la
caricature de ce pourquoi on l'a invité.
En fait, les les les Français ont
beaucoup de mal avec ça parce qu'ils
sont élevés par ce truc très binaire en
fait, très publicitaire.
Bon, après avoir écrit tous ces bouquins
avec toutes ces sources et euh vendu,
vous avez vendu combien de bouquins en
tout ?
Euh là, alors à tout cumuler ce je vous
cache pas que je saurais pas dire
combien vous gagnez.
On doit pas être loin d'un million de
vent si on prend absolument tous les
bouquins depuis le début, depuis 2013.
Combien combien vous gagnez ?
Oh, c'est pas mal. Honnêtement, la
maison d'édition Ring donne d'excellents
pourcentages à ses auteurs, y compris à
ses premiers auteurs. Bon, ça, je donne
pas le détail parce que c'est leur
politique euh et je veux pas créer de
jalousie interne. Donc, enfin, je gagne,
je je gagne bien ma vie honnêtement.
Mais moi enfin je pas mon argent me sert
exclusivement à travailler sur mes
autres bouquins. Je suis très spartiate,
j'ai pas de folie des grandeurs. Ma
maison coûte très peu cher. Je vis en
pleine campagne. Donc je voilà, je je je
fais pas pour je travaille pas pour
l'argent en fait.
Combien vous gagnez ?
Bah c'est ça dépend des années. Si vous
écrivez la France Orange mécanique là
vous gagnez des sous. Mais si après le
bouquin d'après se vend moins bien,
marche moins bien vous gagnez rien du
tout. Donc après entre ça, les impôts,
les fluctuations, les machins, c'est un
métier c'est assez assez aléatoire.
Qu'est-ce que Qu'est-ce que vous
redoutez euh
de ce melting pot avorté selon vous ?
Bah, je redoute
ce phénomène de repli sur soi des
individus euh finissent d'achever en
fait ce qui fut la société française. Et
enfin, moi, peut-être que c'est un tort,
mais je m'y étais un peu attaché quand
même à cette idée, à tout ce que ça
représentait,
à son excellence culturelle et cetera.
Enfin, c'était mes ancêtres, cet
héritage se leg. Alors, c'est peut-être
vilièresque de dire ça, mais enfin c'est
c'est bête. Moi je moi je c'est dans ce
monde là que je me reconnais. Je pense
qu'il y avait encore de belles choses à
faire et justement notamment
c'est la France saucisson pinard c'est
ça
pas spécialement mais ça en fait ça en
fait partie. Je suis client he du
saucisson comme du pinard euh et de tout
un tas d'autres choses. Mais cette ce
niveau d'excellence qu'il soit
patrimoine, terroir et tout ce qu'on
veut, bah ça me je serais assez assez
fort mari de de constater sa
disparition, d'imaginer que mes enfants
vivront dans un monde qui ne ressemblera
pas à ça et que peut-être ce niveau
d'excellence que nous avons atteint,
technologique, scientifique et cetera ne
permettra pas justement à nos
descendants de faire face aux
problématiques écologiques très
importantes qui s'annoncent.
Parce que comme je je le précise aussi
dans le livre, étant donné que le niveau
global baisse baisse de manière très
préoccupante, je pense pas que un pays
d'abruti sera à même dans de de de faire
face à tous les défis qui s'annoncent.
Je pense qu'il faut être très
intelligent et penser sur le long terme,
non seulement pour avoir cette espèce
d'excellence en terme de terroir, de
patrimoine, de ce qu'on veut, de
culture, mais aussi dans une vision
planificatrice de gestion à long terme
et c'est pas vers ça comptant
aujourd'hui, on plus vers Cyril Lanouna.
Donc évidemment, ça me préoccupe un peu.
Question d'internet, euh quels
inconvénients et quels avantages voit-il
à l'immigration ?
Alors euh l'immigration, le problème
c'est que souvent enfin c'est le bloc
quoi, le bloc, l'immigration, il y a
plusieurs immigrations. Il y a
l'immigration qu'on appelle de qualité,
c'est-à-dire des individus qui vont
vendre un haut niveau de compétence. Ben
l'Australie par exemple euh
reçoit quasi exclusivement une
immigration dite de qualité et
objectivement elle était très enfin les
l'Australie bénéficie largement de son
immigration puisque le niveau de
qualification, le niveau de
productivité, le taux d'emploi et cetera
des immigrés en Australie est supérieur
à celui des autochtones.
Nous on est plutôt sur une immigration
de quantité. On n'attire pas la qualité
parce qu'on a une fiscalité délirante.
Justement, les individus en France très
qualifiés, la première chose qu'ils font
euh c'est se barrer à l'étranger parce
que ils savent très bien que là-bas la
fiscalité est différente et qu'il y a
des perspectives euh de valoriser leur
cerveau qui sont bien plus
intéressantes. En France, hélas, le
mouvement est un peu inversé. On attire
des individus très largement
sous-qualifiés, comme je l'ai dit, qui
viennent pas forcément malheureusement
chercher un boulot. euh mais plutôt une
une vie plus confortable qu'elle ne
l'est qu'elle ne l'î chez eux.
D'ailleurs, c'est souvent euh c'est
souvent fantasmé parce que quand ils
sont là, ils se rendent bien compte que
le rêve qu'on leur qu'on leur a vendu ne
correspond pas à la réalité. Donc il y a
des il y a des avantages objectifs avec
certains individus. C'est des questions
individuelles et des désavantages avec
d'autres.
Autre question internet. Que pensez-vous
de la laïcité à la française et de son
modèle d'intégration traditionnelle à
l'opposé du modèle communautariste
anglo-saxon ?
Bah alors, l'assimilation, c'était une
belle idée, mais ça fonctionnait avec un
nombre raisonnable d'immigrés.
C'est quoi un un nombre un nombre
raisonnable ? Bah quand on avait cette
immigration par exemple qui était
polonaise ou qui était portugaise, on
avait une immigration déjà d'une culture
qui était plus proche de la nôtre et
surtout les individus n'avaient pas de
deuxième choix. C'est-à-dire s'il
travaillait pas, il ne mangeait pas,
donc il pouvait pas il pouvait plus il
pouvait plus vivre en France. Donc ils
ont fait cet effort d'assimilation
rapide et important. Et aujourd'hui,
comme on a un contingent d'immigré qui
est beaucoup trop important, il y a plus
cet effort là d'assimilation. Donc euh
on peut en parler, on peut dire qu'il
faudrait donner des prénoms français et
cetera et cetera, ça suffira pas. On est
très loin de de de la réalité de la
problématique.
Autre question d'internet euh que je lis
brut. Que pensent-t-il des patriotes qui
font barrière à la frontière de l'Italie
?
Alors, je pense que on fait génération
euh référence à génération identitaire.
Donc euh qui qui avait fait ça
effectivement, qui était allé se rôle de
l'État, qui était censé le faire
lui-même euh parce que effectivement nos
frontières physiques ne sont pas
contrôlées aujourd'hui. Euh donc c'était
d'une manière un peu spectaculaire de
montrer euh qu'aujourd'hui la France n'a
pas de souveraineté réelle sur sur les
entrées dans son pays. Après ces entrées
physiques concrètes ne représentent que
une goutte d'eau dans l'immigration. En
réalité, l'immigration clandestine
essentiellement, elle est au départ
légal. C'est ça.
Sur visa, sur titre de séjour et ensuite
les individus oublient de repartir. Et
essentiellement les entrées clandestines
ont lieu comme ça. En fait, c'est pas
l'aquarius.
Euh alors, on a 3 millions de visas
délivrés par an, on a 250000 de séjour
50000 titres de séjour, un peu plus. Et
évidemment, on peut pas chiffrer le
nombre d'individus qui repartent
réellement. Euh le ministre de
l'intérieur vous dira qu'il y a à peu
près 400000 clandestins en France et
d'autres indices notamment le nombre de
bénéficiaire de l'AME, euh d'autres
études menées là-dessus euh laissent
penser que ce chiffre est sensiblement
plus important. Mais encore ce sont des
clandestins, c'est impossible de le
dire. Vous avez dans le fou artistique,
vous avez les demandes d'asile. Sur
100000 demandeurs d'asile, vous en avez
70000 qui sont déboutés et vous en avez
10000 qui sont expulsés physiquement. et
les 60000 autres, personne ne sait ce
qu'ils deviennent parce qu'il y a aucun
suivi préfectoral.
Euh, je vais m'excuser une seconde, il
faut absolument que j'aille pisser le
donc je vais te poser je vais te poser
une question qui va te lancer. Tiens, tu
peux me remonter un peu la liste tout en
haut. Tout en haut, tout en haut. Voilà.
Alors, la question c'est comment
travaille-t-il ? Est-ce que sa façon de
travailler le démarque de ses collègues
ou s'informe-t-il ? et j'en profite, je
vais pisser pendant que tu réponds. Je
t'entends, hein.
Ça marche.
Alors alors où tr
alors où travaill-il et comment comment
est-ce que je recue mes informations ?
Bah, depuis la France Orange mécanique,
j'ai eu accès à un certain nombre de
professionnels de la sécurité, des
policiers, des magistrats,
l'étatmajor, le renseignement et cetera.
Donc ça m'a permis de construire un
réseau très efficace et très important
euh d'avoir accès aux études
démographiques
qui qui ont elles plus ou moins accès au
grand médias et donc de vérifier ça euh
de manière la plus scrupuleuse possible.
Je travaille seul, euh ça me prend un
temps considérable de vérification, de
recoupement. Euh donc je sais pas quelle
est quelle est la différence de méthode
d'avec mes collègues. Euh j'ai pas
envoyé moi des stagiaires en scène
Saint-Denis pour me rendre compte qu'il
y avait des types radicalisés qui qui
existaient. Euh je
enfin c'est un travail de longue
haleine. Je vais collecter en fait des
informations sur pour la France
interdite par exemple. Ça fait à peu
près une dizaine d'années que je
collecte des informations sur
l'immigration et je vais mettre à peu
près 1 an pour faire le tri dans cet
énorme maestrome en fait de notes et de
de trucs à vérifier. Et ensuite avec
tout ça donc je vais arriver à une année
d'écriture pour ensuite sortir le
bouquin. Donc je sais pas s'il y a une
méthode miracle ou meilleure que que les
autres à ce niveau-là. Merci pour cette
petite entracte. Force salvatrice,
je t'ai je vous ai entendu de loin
parler de stagier renvoyé dans le 93.
Vous faites référence au bouquin de de
l'homme les deux journalistes du monde
qui ont utilisé des élèves journalistes
pour aller faire une enquête dans le 93.
Est-ce que vous avez lu ce bouquin là ?
J'ai pas encore lu. Enfin, j'ai j'ai eu
quelques bons extraits et je constate
que alors pour eux c'est un enfin
objectivement vu de leur milieu, c'est
un pas géant. C'est-à-dire que c'est il
brisent un tabou réel de par leur
entourage.
Ça a été très critiqué. Ils ont tout le
monde a dit que ça reflétait pas du tout
ce qui se passait dans le 93.
Je pense qu'ils sont au maximum de ce
qu'ils pouvaient faire. Mais il nous
explique que encore une fois c'est une
infime minorité d'individus qui sont
concernés à les entendre dans
l'impression qu'on parle de deux ou
trois types qui qui sont radicalisés. En
fait non, la réalité est un peu plus
critique que celle-là. Euh je les
encourage à aller eux-mêmes plutôt
qu'envoyer des stagiaires là-bas et ils
se rendront compte par eux-mêmes
normalement si tout va bien euh de la
situation. Et objectivement le le niveau
les les on dit souvent pas d'amalgame
mais les musulmans ont tendance à
s'amalgamer tout seul parce que quand il
y a des enquêtes sociologiques qui sont
faites sur ces populations, vous avez à
peu près un tiers des jeunes musulmans
qui vont vous dire qu'ils adhèrent
absolument à tout ce qu'il y a de plus
radical dans l'islam radical. euh port
du nicap pour toutes les femmes et
cetera. Enfin, voyez euh l'État le
l'état islamique, c'est pas si terrible.
Euh enfin bref,
les sources de ça, c'est quoi ?
Oh ! Alors là, vous encore une fois, je
les ai dans mon bouquin, je veux pas
dire de conneries, mais euh vous avez
dans le la partie 3, vous avez toutes
les sources sur ces études-là euh qui
ont été menées par plusieurs instituts
différents. Et donc, c'est un constat,
c'est pas c'est pas une infime minorité.
Objectivement, le problème est un peu
plus important que ça. Je dis pas du
tout que c'est la majorité. Il y a
énormément beaucoup de musulmans
français qui sont très pacifiques à mon
avis, qui n'ont pas du tout l'intention
d'imposer quoi que ce soit à la France.
Mais il y a aussi l'envers de cette
réalité. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a aussi
une jeunesse, en particulier une
jeunesse, qui a envie de se démarquer
clairement, qui a envie d'exister,
d'affirmer une forme de domination
identitaire et qui va passer par
l'islam. L'islam va être le catalyse le
catalyseur de cette de cette
démonstration de force. Moi, je je je
pense pas que l'islam euh ce qu'on me
demande souvent, l'islam n'est-il pas le
principal problème ? Moi, je pense pas.
Je pense que c'est un des un des comment
dire
euh une une des répliques de
l'immigration, mais je pense pas que ce
soit le principal le principal problème
de l'immigration n'est pas l'islam pour
moi.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la liberté
? La liberté de culte ? la liberté cul.
Moi, je suis très je suis tout à fait
favorable à la liberté euh la plus large
possible des individus. Il y a pas de
problème là-dessus. Je veux pas
interdire interdire quoi que ce soit.
Question d'Internet. Pense-t-il que la
France a les capacités militaires
d'empêcher les migrations climatiques
futures ? Est-ce que la France a
vraiment le choix ?
Alors, ça c'est une bonne question. En
général, on nous explique de toute façon
cette immigration qu'on la veuille ou
non, elle va arriver. Elle est déjà en
marche et on peut rien y faire. les
mouvements de population humaine,
personne ne peut s'y opposer. Sauf que
si on regarde un petit peu ce que font
les autres pays, si on regarde ce que
fait l'Australie par exemple ou le
Japon, là on se rend compte qu'on a deux
pays alors cert insulaires mais qui ont
décidé de ne pas avoir recours à cette
immigration de quantité malgré une
dénatalité très forte. Le Japon, je
crois qu'il y a 1,2 enfants par femme au
Japon,
c'est zéro immigration. 11 demandes
d'asile accepté, je crois l'an passé.
11.
et absolument aucune immigration qui
soit extraasiatique, en tout cas
importante. Donc le Japon préfère voir
sa population vieillir, c'est que ça va
lui coûter extrêmement cher, mais ne
veut pas céder à cette immigration.
C'est une question de culture, c'est
comme ça. Et personne ne va au Japon. Il
y a pas de bateaux qui vont au Japon, de
de de migrants qui se noient, il y a pas
de d'ONG qui vont les chercher pour les
amener au Japon. Il y a l'exemple de la
Hongrie aussi. Euh exemple plus
continental, la Hongrie est une une voie
de passage pour l'immigration. Le
président hongrois a demandé enfin
réquisitionner des chômeurs pour faire
construire des des barrières hein
clairement des barrières barbelées avec
des miradors et à qualifié de crime
toute tentative de franchir ses
frontières. Et donc les tentatives de
franchissement se sont effondrées en
quelques heures sont passées de je sais
plus combien de milliers à zéro
quasiment.
Donc quand on parce que personne n'a
envie d'aller dans une prison en
Hongrie, ça qu'on soit migrant ou pas,
ça dissuade. Donc quand on veut,
clairement on peut. La la moi la
question que je pose, c'est pourquoi le
le on ne veut pas en fait alors que le
peuple alors que l'opinion
le le semble le vouloir depuis très
longtemps et que même un président comme
Macron aurait un intérêt objectif du
point de vue de sa popularité à se
ranger derrière cette opinion. Pourquoi
ne le veulent-ils pas ? En fait, ça
c'est une question aussi que je pose
dans le livre.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'aquarius
?
Bah l'aquarius, pas grand-chose. C'est
alors voilà, si c'est 40 types qui
transitent qu'on va chercher euh
40 types, des fois c'est 300 sur un
bateau ou un peu plus. Mais ça fait
objectivement ça fait pas beaucoup de
monde. Après, c'est vrai que c'est un
principe. C'est un principe. Est-ce que
on doit oui ou non aller chercher des
individus au large des côtes libiennes ?
Je vois pas bien ce qu'on a y faire.
Est-ce qu'on doit aller les chercher
là-bas ? Pourquoi on ne les dépose pas à
Alger ou au Maroc où ce sont des pays
sûrs qui accueillent euh qui accueillent
les les migrants clandestins ? Euh mais
ils ne veulent pas rester là-bas. Ils ne
veulent pas aller là-bas. qui veulent
venir ici en France et moralement
soutenir ces ONG qui font le boulot en
fait des passeurs. He faut rappeler que
le trafic de chair humaine des migrants
rapporte des milliers d'euros par tête
au passeur. C'est un trafic qui est en
passe de devenir extrêmement enfin
lucratif. Il est déjà on parle de je
sais plus quel quelles sont les sommes,
j'en parle dans le bouquin mais c'est
astronomique. Donc
pourquoi vous dites qu'ils font le
boulot dépasseur ? Ils prennent pas un
rond, ils évitent à des gamins de se
noyer. Non, ils prennent pas un rond
parce que si si leur monnaie, elle est
morale en fait. Euh ces gens-là, ils
augmente leur valeur sociale en faisant
ça. Faut pas croire que les les gens qui
vont aider les réfugiés, qui vont aller
construire des puits au sel ou qui vont
envoyer des sacs de riz n'en ont aucun
bénéfice. Ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est
faux. En fait, c'est une hypocrisie
absolue.
Les valeurs chrétiennes, c'est être son
prochain.
Oui, mais je trouve
les scout les scoutes unitaires de
France vont creuser des pux au Bénin.
Oui, mais je trouve dommage que on ces
valeurs chrétiennes ne s'interrogent pas
un peu davantage, qu'il y ait pas de
théologien de théologiens plus plus
aguéris qui se demandent finalement euh
à partir du moment où on en bénéficie
socialement de nos actes où on rentre
comme ça avec une espèce d'oréole comme
Couchner l'a fait avec ses sacs de riz,
en réalité on n'ayant absolument rien à
des des africains qui étaient là
juste pour tapisser le fond de la scène
et qui étaient qui sont utilisés. C'est
c'est une marchandise objectivement. Euh
à partir du moment où on utilise comme
ça des gens pour sa propre estime de
soi, pour sa propre gloire sociale,
est-ce que c'est bien chrétien
finalement ?
Est-ce que vous connaissez Saint-Martin
?
Je le connais pas personnellement mais
j'ai j'ai entendu parler. Oui.
Il a fait quoi Saint-Martin ? Alors,
écoutez, vous ça fait longtemps que j'ai
pas mis les pieds au catéchisme. Celui
qui a partagé le manteau avec, c'est ça,
avec le le le malheureux sans abri,
c'est ça, c'était un un romain, un
officier de la de l'armée romaine, je
crois.
Bah, écoutez,
si la vraie question, c'est se demander
est-ce qu'il a réellement aidé la
personne à qui il a fait ce don ? Ça
aussi l'aide. On se demande jamais euh
est-ce que concrètement les gens
bénéficient de notre aide ? Si vous
aidez quelqu'un et que vous lui donnez
quelque chose, est-ce que concrètement
il en bénéficie ? La question on se la
pose même pas tellement on est persuadé
que ce qu'on fait nous est bon. Le don,
il est bon. Point. On se demande pas si
en réalité notre aide ne va pas euh
faire empirer la situation de l'individu
qui va la recevoir.
Il faut faire quoi avec les
Moi, je je j'en sais rien. Moi
personnellement, je fais rien. Euh ne
faisons rien, c'est plus prudent comme
dit Becket. Euh si si
moi je fais rien mais je trouve ça
si un gamin de 25 ans qui est en train
de boire la tasse parce qu'il sait pas
nager et que il a cru à un rêve
occidental parce que son pays a été
ravagé par les occidentaux. Ah non mais
parce que moi je suis moi j'ai j'ai une
morale voilà j'ai une éducation
chrétienne et cetera ma qualité d'humain
fait que je vais tout faire pour le
tirer de là mais je prétends pas oui
mais je prétends pas échapper à c à
pourquoi vous dites que les mecs sur
l'aquarius ils essayent de tirer partie
de de ça
socialement parlant j'en je suis
persuadé que la cette espèce d'identité
que se trouvent les militants
promigrants
qui sont d'ailleurs relativement souvent
des marginaux ou des retraités.
C'est c'est c'est factuel.
Comment vous avez des stats là-dessus
des margin ? J'en ai rencontré un
certain nombre et
c'est des punk à chiens avec des dreads,
c'est ça ? Oh non, c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu réducteur, mais qui
objectivement euh sont en quête
identitaire et le fait d'avoir même de
prendre position pour l'immigration lors
d'un dîner et cetera augmente euh la
valeur sociale de votre personne. Ça
c'est un fait parce que aujourd'hui la
morale est une valeur absolument
déterminante. Si on n pas la bonne
morale, on peut pas entrer dans cette
espèce de caste progressiste supérieur
dont je parlais. Vous avez vous avez
déjà rencontré des migrants ?
Oui, des
moi mais je vous dis ça les individus
euh les individus je on on peut
absolument comprendre tous les types
d'individus, leurs choix fondamentaux.
Vous les avez rencontrés où ? Et c'était
quelle nationalité ? Par quel parcours
ils étaient passés ?
Alors ceux que j'avais rencontré était
justement entré avec la fil enfin plus
récemment était entré avec la filière
titre de séjour et j'oublie de repartir
et alors c'était alors il y avait des
individus qui faisaient des efforts
énormes pour travailler au noir pour
c'était les fameux trucs de livraison
Uber
où il fais absolument mais oui mais
c'est de l'esclavagisme
donc je peux pas objectivement me
réjouir de cette situation là c'est pas
pourquoi vous dites objectivement tout
le
Bah parce que c'est objectif, c'est le
contraire de subjectif et et il me
semble que c'est enfin un raisonnement
rationnel pour le coup. J'essaie d'avoir
ce quand je dis j'essaie de comprendre
au maximum les individus y compris les
progressistes.
C'est quoi l'objectivité ?
Bah je pense de pas avoir de vision
moralement idéologiquement tronquée,
c'est-à-dire de pas imposer à la réalité
ce qu'on voudrait qu'elle soit. En fait
euh c'est pour ça que mes écrits ont
l'air plutôt dystopiques, contre
utopique euh parce que bah en Arcadie,
la mort est aussi hein, comme dit le
proverbe. C'est-à-dire que même si on a
des très bonnes intentions et bien
souvent malheureusement les conséquences
de ces bonnes intentions et de ces
bonnes actions bah sont dommageables
finalement autant pour les individus
concernés que pour soi.
Vous avez déjà été en Afrique ? Vous
avez déjà été à Mayotte ? À Mayotte ?
Non non, j'ai jamais mis les pieds à
Mayotte. Par contre, j'ai je connais pas
mal de gens qui qui bossent et qui qui
m'ont qui m'ont expliqué un peu ce qui
s'y passait.
Ils font quoi Mayotte ? C'est c'est des
autochtones ou
Ah oui, non, c'est des enfin c'est des
essentiellement mes sources étaient même
pas d'autochtones mais de de
continentaux, enfin de métro euh qui
travaillaient là-bas.
Il faisait quoi là-bas ? Euh c'était
essentiellement des fonctionnaires euh
polices euh parce que justement enfin
quand il y a eu les événements, les
tensions on va dire euh pour le dire
poliment entre la population locale et
euh les immigrés comoréens euh où il y
avait eu pas mal d'agitations, j'avais
eu quelques quelques rapports là-dessus
euh de visu
que le les maoré exploitent les enjoins,
c'est à peu près le même principe, non ?
Bah c'est ce que c'est ce qui se dit
après. Voilà, ce sont des ressentis
locaux. des situations qui sont très
tendues, il y a tout un tas de enfin de
considérations qui entrent en jeu. C'est
pour ça je me enfin je je j'utilise
assez peu, vous l'aurez peut-être
remarqué dans mes bouquins les
témoignages direct parce que justement
ils sont chargés très fortement de ces
connotations idéologiques, morales et
cetera. Donc il reflètent des opinions
mais pas forcément des réalités.
C'est le votre idéal pour la société
française c'est quoi ?
Non moi je refuse diamétralement la
notion d'idéal.
Je vous le dis, il y a pas enfin je
pense pas qu'il y avait c'était mieux
avant, il y avait un âge d'or machin
tout ça. Je suis pas du tout dans cette
optique là. Moi j'ai pas de truc à
proposer, pas de programme.
C'est plutôt une vision
anthropologique. Ouais. Voilà.
Ethnologique.
Ethnologique, c'est ma formation
principale au départ, c'est
l'anthropologie. Donc c'est plutôt
là-dessus que que je me base.
Question question d'internet. Croi-t-il
en Dieu ?
C'est c'est je je préfère pas me
hasarder une réponse parce que là ça y
ça irait trop loin dans dans la
réflexion. J'ai j'aurais besoin de trop
de temps là. B
on a le temps làin. Non
non non mais je enfin ça c'est c'est un
peu comme l'isoloire il y a une part de
mystère.
Vous avez identifié des problèmes ?
Est-ce que vous avez identifié des
solutions ?
C'est pareil sur la le volet solution.
J'aurais l'impression d'être un
politicien si je fournissais comme ça
clé en main. Voilà ce qu'il faut faire
et tout ça et j'aurais l'impression de
rentrer dans une éème euh escroquerie en
fait he en proposant des trucs
miraculeux qui contentrai tout le monde.
Ça n'existe pas. Je préfère attirer
l'attention sur les problèmes et ce qui
pourrait en devenir plutôt qu'essayer de
de proposer des pistes miraculeuses.
Vous faites partie de ceux qui soulèvent
les problèmes sans apporter de solution.
C'est ça.
C'est très mal perçu en France.
C'est sans doute très mal perçu. Les
messagers, on les aime pas du tout. Euh
on veut des solutions, on veut beaucoup
de démagogie. Euh la monsieur Moyen pour
le coup est extrêmement demandeur de de
voilà de il veut euh un comment dire un
homme providentiel ou une femme
providentielleur.
Voilà, il croit absolument en ça. Il
pense qu'il va pouvoir rester tranquille
devant la télévision, que ça va bien se
passer, que quelqu'un va le sauver. Euh
il a il a cette espérance un peu
délirante à mon avis. Enfin, pour moi,
il y a les deux formes, c'est le
désespoir et l'espoir sont deux formes
de de d'erreur en fait et que quand on
s'enferme dans dans une forme comme dans
l'autre, on ne regarde plus la réalité
en fait.
Est-ce que Est-ce que le débat sur
l'immigration, l'insécurité est pas
repris par des partis politiques
qui utilisent ça pour catalyser la haine
et la rage des gens ? Bah pour catalyser
la NLRE, je sais pas pour euh s'en
servir à des fins tactiques, là euh
c'est clair que enfin je pense que ce
débat fait rage dans beaucoup de partis
politiques dit traditionnels que la
France insoumise par exemple euh
est en passe d'exploser sur cette
questionlà parce que
un peu comme en Allemagne, non ? Oui,
parce que objectivement la base de ce
parti euh a une opinion sur
l'immigration qui n'est pas du tout
celle qui est représentée par les
por-parole, par Mélenchon lui-même, par
euh par les discours en fait, mais ils
sont allés tellement loin dans leur
discours euh de les l'immigration est
une chance nous enrichit et cetera
qu'ils peuvent plus, ils seraient plus
crédibles de changer complètement, de
faire machinaria là-dessus. Donc, ils
vont se suicider sur cette question
parce qu'électoralement, c'est un frein
absolu pour eux. Et je pense que Macron
lui-même s'est posé la question, est-ce
qu'il y aurait pas moyen de récupérer
beaucoup de popularité en faisant comme
Sarkozi, c'est-à-dire simplement avec
des discours un peu un peu à la colon,
un peu voilà carchérisant, ça suffirait
et je pense que ça suffirait
mais il est entouré par tellement enfin
ce système de cours, il y a les médias
et cetera qu'il a trop peur de ça et
donc il osera pas le faire. Je pense
ce qu'a dit Colomb, c'est vrai, c'est
pas vrai, c'était un effet de manche,
c'était
un colis piégé, c'était quoi ?
Il y a un peu des deux. Il a voulu
considérablement emmerder son
successeur, ça c'est sûr.
Rappelez-nous ce qu'il a dit.
Euh que en gros la situation enfin alors
ça dépend, il y a eu plusieurs propos.
Il y a eu ceux qui étaient tenus en
offre quelques jours avant la démission.
Comme quoi dans 5 à 6 ans en gros si on
ne faisait rien, la situation serait
incontrôlable et irréversible. et il
parlait d'une crise majeure, une sorte
de guerre civile euh dans les banlieux
françaises. Et en démissionnant, il a
répété à peu près la même chose. Nous
sommes plus côte à côte, nous sommes
face- à face. Euh un truc très
dramatique, mais je pense qu'il était
ministre de l'intérieur. Il a vu les
mêmes choses que moi parce que j'ai des
informations aussi sur l'état de la
situation réelle en France. Et donc il a
tout d'un coup on lui a mis le nez
dedans en fait et là il est sorti de de
l'idéal et il a vu la réalité des
choses. il a vu tous les jours les get
flic la les les ce qui se passe le
niveau de violence dans la société
française le niveau de tension est assez
incroyable et les rapports vraiment du
renseignement de l'étatmajor et cetera
sont très alarmants et normalement le
politicien en France les les met au
panier et se concentre uniquement sur sa
communication et lui je pense qu'il a dû
en lire deux trois et que ça l'a ça l'a
sincèrement
ébranlé
après la vie continue il est maire de
Lyon Sinon, tout va bien.
Il faut bien manger.
Il faut bien manger. Voilà. Et puis il
peut pas lui-même, il était ministre de
l'intérieur. Le ministre de l'intérieur
en France n'a aucun pouvoir. En fait, le
français l'aime bien parce qu'il tient
des discours. Il y a le carcher machin,
c'est un tremplin populaire mais la clé
de l'insécurité c'est la justice qu'il
a. Donc le ministre de l'intérieur,
c'est juste le chef de la police. La
police fait ce qu'elle peut. Donc il n'a
aucun pouvoir réel. Mais c'est une
manière encore une fois de divertir le
citoyen. Ça
on en est où avec la justice ?
La justice française, c'est un c'est la
grande question de la France en Orge
mécanique, c'est pourquoi dans le code
pénal un viol, c'est écrit 15 ans de
prison.
Pourquoi concrètement la la le
réquisition c'est 10, la condamnation
c'est 8 et finalement la peine
réellement effectuée ça va être 4 ou 5
avec un aménagement de 2 ou 3 ans avec
port de bracelet à la maison et cetera.
Pourquoi ? Il y a zé il y a 1 % des
violeurs qui sont condamnés. Euh
pourquoi on en est à ce niveau-là en
fait ? Et ça c'est la vraie question là.
J'ai vu un papier récemment des juges de
Bobini qui expliquait la justice des
mineurs, on sert à rien parce que euh
ils commettent des délits en tant que
mineurs qui sont d'une gravité
épouvantable, des violents en réunion,
des lynchages et cetera. Et qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on fasse ? on les
place dans des machins d'aid l'enfance
et où il fument du cheat et ils
trafiquent entre eux et on les envoie en
vacances mais ça sert à rien.
Donc la justice, elle est très très loin
de prendre la mesure de la réalité de
l'ultraviolence aujourd'hui.
Guillia, ça parlait de quoi
Guilla ? Alors c'est bah Gérard Colon
aurait pu écrire le scénario, hein.
C'est vous avez dans quelques années
dans un futur proche un flic. Ils sont à
bout aujourd'hui. Vous avez vu qu'il se
ils se flinguent jusque dans les sous
les fenêtres de Matignon euh parce que
vraiment c'est un métier très difficile.
On a vu une vidéo récemment de type qui
insultait les flics et tout ça et on a
et même Calv a trouvé que c'était
scandaleux. Euh, sauf que ça c'est tous
les jours. Vous allez dans un
commissariat euh de police, n'importe
lequel hein, même en province, partout
et vous verrez euh la pression
psychologique que peut subir un policier
aujourd'hui face à des individus qui ont
parfaitement compris qu'ils étaient
impunis, qu'ils ne risquaient pas
grand-chose
pour une paye de merde.
Pour une paye de merde. Absolument pour
obéir à une hiérarchie dont il ne
connent absolument pas la la soumission
idéologique au aux décideurs
gouvernementaux.
Euh, il faut une abnégation incroyable
pour être policier aujourd'hui en
France. Et un jour, je pense que un de
ces flics là va se retrouver dans un de
ces guetapans. Il y en a à peu près tous
les soirs. Donc à l'eau, il y a une
poubelle qui brûle. Les flics vont parce
que il faut accompagner les pompiers et
il y a une vingtaine de types qui
tombent sur la bagnole. Et les flics, un
jour, on va tomber sur le type qui aura,
je sais pas qui qui aura passé un cap
dans sa tête et lui, il va pas il va pas
se sauver. il va sortir son arme, il va
tirer dans le tas, il va faire des morts
et on va avoir un scénario à la 2005 et
on va avoir en plus les actes
terroristes qui vont se greffer
là-dessus et comme l'a dit récemment
paraît-il le général de Vill à son
frère, on n' pas les moyens, on n pas
les hommes pour faire face à une
situation d'embragement généralisée
comme celle qu'on a connu en 2005. Et
donc ça c'est Guia. Donc en quelques
jours, on se rend compte qu'une société
technologique développée
basée sur enfin d'une complexité
pharamineuse peut s'effondrer en fait.
Vous avez cité autre question internet,
il a cité Vincent Mineuro précédemment.
Que pensent-il de l'effondrement et du
réchauffement climatique à venir, son
anticipation sur les tensions en France,
l'effondrement
écologique, l'effondrement des
ressources, l'effondrement de l'énergie.
Vous avez un avis là-dessus ? Alors, je
suis je partage un peu les inquiétudes
de monsieur Mignoro
sur enfin c'est un caractère très
préoccupant de ce qui se passe et le
fait que on ne semble pas prendre la
mesure de ça, on parle toujours de
croissance, la démographie et cetera,
c'est génial
mais on voit pas les ennuis majeurs qui
arrivent. On parle beaucoup d'écologie
mais jamais non plus de démographie qui
est quand même la première enfin la base
de toute écologie me semble-t-il
démographique.
Un peu maltusien ça non ?
C'est un Oui, c'est un peu maltusien
mais objectivement c'est le cas. Enfin,
si les espèces disparaissent, si la
pollution est telle aujourd'hui, c'est
essentiellement par la ce qu'on peut
appeler la prolifération humaine. Euh
donc tant qu' enfin on on ne peut pas
prendre le problème, c'est encore une
fois, il est encore une fois moral, on
peut pas regarder ça en face justement
sans s'accuser, sans se faire peur de se
dire "Oui, mais de quoi on parle ? Les
êtres humains font ce qu'ils veulent.
S'ils veulent se reproduire, se
reproduisent." Oui, moi je je vous l'ai
dit, je suis pas pour interdire les aux
individus de se reproduire. Mais
simplement euh je faut regarder en face
les conséquences de de ce qui se passe.
Une planète à 15 milliards d'individus,
c'est pas la même chose qu'une planète à
6 milliards.
Autre question d'internet. Alors pour
vous, le plus dur pour la France, c'est
la délinquence de rue ou c'est la
délinquence fiscale ?
Alors ça dépend si on parle du coup
est-ce que est-ce que les les coles
blancs sont autochtones ? Est-ce que les
coles blancs sont sont quoi ?
Oh, je pense qu'ils sont assez largement
autochtones.
parce que il y a ce phénomène comme je
l'ai dit euh d'effondrement du capital
social. Donc les individus sont de plus
en plus tentés par la triche parce que
les les les types qui bossent
aujourd'hui en France se disent c'est
super mais moi j'ai pas envie qu'on me
prenne 60 % du fruit de mon travail pour
le reverser à des types qui n'en foutent
pas une. Concrètement leur raisonnement
c'est celui-là et donc il préfèrent
tricher un peu. Il préfèrent essayer
tenter leur chance barrer en Belgique.
Se barrer en Belgique beaucoup le font
ou voilà ou mais à tous les niveaux he
d'ailleurs. C'est-à-dire le type qui va
avoir un congé maladie plus long que
prévu. Enfin, on voit tous ces
phénomènes là qui augmentent en fait. Et
ça c'est une forme de de refus en fait
de de cette de participer, de continuer
à courir tout seul alors que les autres
cour un peu moins vite et tapent un peu
plus dedans et se font plaisir. Mais on
peut c'est difficile de mettre sur le
même plan les deux les deux délinquences
puisque celle encore une fois qui est
très fortement ressentie par la fameuse
population périphérique, la population
d'Am, c'est celle qui va rayer sa
bagnole le matin. Et ça pour un
français, un monsieur moyen, c'est un
drame qui est bien plus important que
tout le reste en fait. Donc évidemment,
la délinquence fiscale coûte très cher
aussi de ce sont des des dizaines de
milliards d'euros. Mais la délinquence
aussi, enfin la petite délinquence,
voilà les dégradations de biens, les
agressions gratuites, je crois qu'on a
1000 agressions gratuite par jour en
France. Grite ça veut dire sans mobile
crapuleux. Bah ça coûte très cher aussi
hein. On est à des dizaines voir des
centaines de milliards par an. des
centaines de milliards,
c'est difficile à évaluer. Il y a
beaucoup d'économistes qui se sont
penchés là-dessus. Certains ont trouvé
que ça coûtait plusieurs centaines de
milliards d'euros par an.
Il sortaient d'où ces économistes là ?
Alors celui-là, je je crois que c'est
Jacques Bichot, donc il faudrait le
googliser pour moi parce que j'ai j'ai
pas l'idée précise de son de son de son
de sa bio, de son CV,
de son parcours idéologique.
Il a eu, je crois que Capital avait fait
un truc là-dessus et avait parlé d'une
trentaine de milliards par an. Après, ça
dépend de ce qui est pris en compte, le
coût de la justice, des prisons et
cetera.
Autre autre question d'internet. Quelle
analyse fait-il du fonctionnement de
l'économie mondiale et des puissances
occidentales qui encouragent les
conflits dans la région
proie une forte immigration ? Est-il
légitime de fuir la misère ? L'Occident
n'est-il pas la première cause de
l'immigration qui l'atteint ?
Je pense pas que Alors sur la croissance
démographique africaine, il est clair
que l'Occident est le est le responsable
principal. Objectivement euh si
l'Occident n'était pas si
interventionniste
euh il y aurait pas question sur la
démographie
non je je relie la question.
Quelle analyse fait-il du fonctionnement
de l'économie mondiale et des puissances
occidentales qui encourage les conflits
dans les régions en proie à une forte
immigration ? Est-il légitime de fuir la
misère ? L'Occident n'est-il pas la
cause première de l'immigration qui
l'atteint ? de dire que les le fait que
l'Occident va déstabiliser, s'amuser,
faire mumuse avec des régimes orientaux
euh change fortement le sort migratoire
euh est un peu euh est un peu simplifié
parce que en réalité euh même si la
Libye ne gère plus du tout l'immigration
que comme elle a pu le gérer du temps de
Kaddafi, euh ce serait pour autant
extrêmement facile de la stopper là. Euh
donc c'est une c'est une manière de
défausser le problème en fait et
d'accuser euh les Américains et Sarkozy
et compagnie euh de de nous valeur ça.
Mais là pour le coup euh c'est pas le
cas.
Est-ce que c'est légitime de fuir la
misère ?
Ah bah je enfin je vous dis tout
comportement enfin j'ai du mal à dire
d'un comportement qu'il n'est pas
légitime. Euh il s'explique et il faut
expliquer les comportements des
individus. Euh c'est ça aussi, c'est
qu'on a tellement peu l'habitude de
parler des individus sans euh qu'il y
ait forcément une connotation derrière
qui soit péjorative ou stigmatisante que
c'est difficile de le faire. Euh je
parle effectivement je parle de
l'immigration, du coup de l'immigration,
mais ça veut pas dire que je suis euh
contre les individus. C'est que si je
constate que les retraités les retraites
coûtent beaucoup d'argent, ça veut pas
dire que je veux déporter les retraités.
C'est pas ça
faire du compost avec.
Bah c'est vrai que ça sera ça ça
pourquoi pas c'est chacun a le droit
d'avoir son son idée sur la question. On
préfère les brûler au bilan carbone et
désastreux. Mais
question à propos de Maltus, que
pensent-il du darwinisme social et
d'Herbert Spencer ?
Spencer, j'en passe, j'en pense pas
grand-chose. Avait eu avait un petit peu
tordu les idées de notre ami Darwin
pour justifier
certaines formes. Alors, je je veux pas
prêter à Spencer des idées qu'il n'a pas
eu mais il me semble que ça permettait
euh de justifier en gros une forme
d'ordre social en se basant sur les les
théories darwiniennes.
En gros, les bourgeois sont bourgeois
parce que ils sont ils ont enfin leur
génome, il est mieux et cetera. Enfin,
il me semble que c'est ça. Donc làdus,
tu
es crétin quoi.
Je Ah non, je dis pas du tout ça. Je je
pense que c'est peut-être quelqu'un de
très brillant. J'avoue que j'ai pas lu
l'intégralité de de de ces livres. Donc
je veux pas prononcer de jugement comme
ça. Il faut que j'étudie la question un
peu plus avant de me prononcer.
Bon, pour résumer trivialement vos
bouquins, du moins le dernier sur
l'immigration, on va où là ?
On va où ? difficile de savoir la
Castagne, on va la guerre civile, on va
sur des pouvoirs politiques qui sont
complètement impuissants, on est dans un
déni, on est dans quoi là ?
Bah les les pouvoirs politiques peuvent
aussi bien continuer à aller vers
l'impuissance, c'est-à-dire cette espèce
de communication, de verbiage permanent
et de refus de tenter quoi que ce soit
ou aller justement à l'inverse vers une
forme de toute puissance autoritaire.
Euh ça, j'en sais rien. Les courbes euh
je le dis dans le bouquin, elles sont ce
qu'elles sont. Euh mais une courbe, ça
peut s'inverser, ça peut il peut y avoir
un événement, une crise économique ou
quoi que ce soit qui peut changer
complètement intégralement la donne en
fait. Et ça, je peux pas euh, je suis
pas cartomancien, je peux pas vous dire
euh tout va se passer comme ça. Je sais
pas, je sais pas si on aura plutôt une
situation de de comme l'a dit Colomb de
guerre civile ou plutôt une situation à
la Welbec que finalement euh le français
va continuer à se dire que tant pis et
subir la situation et petit à petit, on
va se retrouver dans une forme de
d'espèce de soumission.
J'en sais rien ça l'avenir je je voilà
je dis si la situation reste telle
qu'elle est à l'instant les projections
démographiques font que la France va
changer complètement euh voilà c'est
tout ce que je peux dire
à combien de temps
alors les autochtones françaises
seraient minoritaires à peu près autour
de 2060 si on en restait à la situation
actuelle ça veut dire sans grande
modification l'immigration reste à peu
près ce qu'elle est naissances et
cetera, la mortalité Enfin, si tout
reste à peu près constant, ce serait à
peu près une sorte de calcul comme ça
qu'on peut faire. Mais c'est pas que la
France he vous avez les pays
scandinaves, vous avez l'Allemagne, vous
avez l'Italie. Enfin, c'est c'est
général en fait.
Après voilà, c'est les citoyens sont
libres de ils sont souverains, c'est à
eux de choisir leur destin et pourquoi
pas.
Comment ils font si selon vous ils sont
ils sont mal informés ?
Ben voilà, c'est aussi un des mon livre
fait aussi fait le procès de la
démocratie mais fait aussi le procès de
ces individus du de nous-même, de
monsieur moyen, de moi-même en fait. Euh
si on est aussi majoritaire, si on a ces
idéesl si on ne supporte plus ce paysage
médiatique qui ne nous représente pas,
universitaire, administratif, politique,
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on subit la situation
? Pourquoi on continue à enfin moi on me
demande tout le temps mais qui sont les
vrais responsables de tout ça ? Et bien
peut-être que c'est nous en fait parce
que
en quoi on ne pourrait pas imposer cette
souveraineté ? En quoi on pourrait pas
créer des médias qui soient
représentatifs ? En quoi on pourrait pas
diffuser des informations utiles ?
Pourquoi on ne le fait pas en fait ? Et
là, ça pose une question un peu plus
métaphysique profonde, c'est que
peut-être il y a une forte de une sorte
de fatigue d'exister dans ces peuples
européens, je sais pas forme de
contreraumatisme de ce qui a pu se
passer le siècle dernier et que
peut-être ils sont enchantés à
disparaître. Il n'y voit pas d'objection
majeure. Euh, j'avais vu l'émission où
Yan Bartes recevait Michel Onfay. Onf
disait "Les blancs vont disparaître mais
ça me dérange pas du tout." Bartesz
disait oui, c'est important de dire que
ça vous dérange pas. Est-ce que vous
n'avez pas peur que ça fasse le jeu du
Front National ? On peut penser comme
ça. On peut se dire que c'est pas grave
ou au pire que ça fait le jeu du Front
National. Chacun est libre d'avoir sa
vision mais il faut il faut assumer les
conséquences. Il faut ses
responsabilités. Il faut pas dire c'est
la faute des autres, j'ai rien pu faire.
Ça c'est pas possible. On peut pas dire
j'ai eu peur d'Émic Caron donc j'ai rien
fait. Euh c'est que chacun doit faire ce
qu'il estime bon de faire pour lui-même.
Mais le principe de responsabilité
individuelle en France, il est plus
vraiment à l'ordre du jour en fait.
Émerric Caron, c'est votre copain ? Bah
c'est un alors je l'ai je l'ai je l'ai
croisé qu'une fois et c'était pas un
échange d'une cordialité euh absolue.
Peut-être que si je le croisais par
ailleurs en dehors de de tout contexte
euh sans aller jusqu'à manger de la
viande, on pourrait peut-être boire un
verre et qu'on s'entendrait peut-être,
je sais pas, qu'on pourrait parler au
moins un petit peu, que il serait pas
enfermé dans ce rôle d'indigné
inquisiteur
qui qu'il tenait à l'écran. Euh je sais
pas, moi je je parle à tout le monde, il
y a pas de problème. Si s'il veut qu'on
se rencontre, j'accepte.
Ici ?
Oh ici ou ailleurs. Euh moi, je j'ai
j'ai pas de problème avec ça. Je peux
parler à n'importe qui.
Question d'internet. Que pensent-t-il de
l'influence des États et des sociétés
privées sur la vie privée des citoyens
grâce au contrôle du numérique ?
Alors le contrôle du numérique, c'est
vrai, il y a quelques années, j'étais
optimiste, bêtement optimiste là-dessus
et je pensais que Internet ne serait pas
euh repris en main rapidement par les
les grandes puissances euh étatiques,
idéologique et cetera. Je me trompais
lourdement puisqu'on a vu que
aujourd'hui les contenus notamment de
Facebook, de Twitter, de YouTube, Google
et cetera sont repris en main par
justement cet itensia. Euh il y a eu des
réunions qui ont été faites, hein, moi
j'ai eu des témoignages très précis de
la réunion des représentants de Facebook
notamment euh qui ont rencontré les
décodeurs du monde euh des intox
Libération, les Inrog, enfin bref euh
tous les les journalistes euh comme
lesquels il est convenu de penser et euh
ils se sont accordés sur le fait
d'exposer ou non, de mettre en avant ou
non leur contenu selon l'opinion de ces
grands médias en fait. Donc en gros, si
le contenu euh d'un poste Facebook n'est
pas validé par les par le monde et par
cette cette bonne pensée, et bien il
sera moins exposé que les autres. Et je
l'ai constaté moi-même avec ma ma propre
page Facebook. Et donc voilà, si on
n'est pas dans la bonne dans la bonne
direction, on perd sa visibilité. Et il
y a des pages Twitter qui sont censurées
arbitrairement, il y a des chaînes
YouTube qui sont qui sont banies. Euh
voilà, le le la reprise de contrôle
d'Internet depuis Trump a a eu lieu et a
a bien eu lieu, je pense.
Question d'internet, vous en avez
d'autres les gars ou pas du tout ?
Ils sont très fatigués d'habitude.
D'habitude, il y a plein de il y a plein
de questions.
Euh si vous avez des si vous deviez
assumer la tête d'un parti politique,
moi je le principe de politique ne me
plaît pas des masses parce que la notion
de séduction est à mon avis trop trop
importante. Donc qui dit séduction dit
mensonge et démagogie et enfin c'est
vraiment un autre métier et ça m' c'est
pas c'est pas un métier qui m'intéresse.
L'état de la presse pour vous, c'est
définitif ? Euh c'est mort.
Non, non, c'est pas définitif parce que
comme je l'ai dit, il y a beaucoup
d'individus qui sont dans cette
profession et qui sont victimes de cette
profession.
Effectivement, certains sont assez
récupérables mais d'autresquels
pourraient bah je je peux pas encore une
fois donner de nom. Euh non, mais enfin
voilà, les individus que j'ai pu citer,
je sais pas, je suis pas sûr que Yan
Bartes un jour vote du Pontignan par
exemple. Euh je je
Non mais parce que son son l'importance
de son implication militante est telle
que vraiment son identité est fondée sur
euh sur euh sur sur ses prises de
position politique.
Non mais du de du Pontignan qui dit
qu'il veut appliquer les mêmes mesures
que d'ertumeurs
de cannabis. J'ai dit du Ponignon pour
dire ça. J'aurais pu dire même pour
Bartes l'extrême droite commence à
Baouin.
C'est le spectre est plus large que ça
si vous voulez. Euh mais je suis pas je
peux pas condamner définitivement la
presse parce que il y a cet effet bande
de sardine qui peut arriver et que j'ai
l'impression d'observer d'ailleurs.
C'est-à-dire que on s'adapte à l'air du
temps quand même. De plus en plus, on va
inviter des individus qui sont pas tout
à fait alignés parce qu'on sait que ça
fait de l'audience, ça permet, c'est des
soupapes un peu de décompression, ça
permet à monsieur Moyen de se dire quand
même voilà, ils en parlent un peu donc
ils sont pas si vendus que ça et que
peut-être par effet d'entraînement par
Davom, par des même des individus comme
Colomb ou Mar
Davom, on les aime pas du tout.
On va sortir d'ailleurs un petit scoop
les enfants. On va vous sortir 6 minutes
de Dav et l'homme au festival du
journalisme de de couture sur Garodonne.
Vous allez voir, vous allez vous
régaler. Ce sera pour votre petit Noël.
On vous le met, on vous le met bien au
chaud.
Et ben les les les Davom et ces
individus sentent qu'il y a l'air du
temps, qu'il faut s'y adapter, que c'est
le moment et pour ne pas perdre
complètement le contrôle en fait euh
faire ce virage, ce fameux virage, mais
il y a une inertie énorme dans la
profession lent.
C'est continuer de manger à la cantine,
c'est ça ?
Oui, c'est ça. C'est exactement ça. Et
il faudrait que des investisseurs aient
le cran de tenter de lancer des médias
qui pour le coup à l'ancienne vivent de
leur lectorat. c'est-à-dire cible une
opinion et dépend uniquement de ces
lecteurs-là plutôt que de subvention ou
de financiers et cetera et que c'est pas
les enfermer dans le même mode de
pensée.
Ah pas forcément. Si euh ils dépendent
vraiment pour le coup des lecteurs, ils
ont une obligation de de véracité qui
est un peu plus importante. Euh s'ils
ont envie d'être lu, ils sont obligés
quand même de coller à une image du réel
qui est plus en phase avec celle avec
enfin avec le réel qui est ressenti par
les par les citoyens.
Euh si un financier lance une telle
opération, il sera suivi par d'autres et
cetera. Ça va en désinhiber un certain
nombre. Et là, on peut assister une
forme de virage assez global. Mais pour
l'instant, le truc est bien qu'adasser,
c'est pas encore le cas.
Vous avez des conseils pour les jeunes
générations ?
Bah, ça dépend.
Ne pas devenir journaliste par exemple,
ne pas imaginer que la jouée à la perno
est la bonne tactique en se disant quand
j'arriverai après 40 ans de carrière au
JT de TF1, je pourrais dire ce que je
veux. Ça, à mon avis, je déconseille
parce que vous le ferez qu'une fois,
vous allez vous faire plaisir mais vous
allez disparaître des écrans et 40 ans
d'investissement pour pour ça, c'est pas
hyper pertinent. Je pense plutôt qu'il
faut essayer de créer des solutions
alternatives, des médias alternatifs,
des manières de diffuser l'information.
originaux peut-être hein, euh en tout
cas hors de ce système euh qui qui qui
va vous digérer sinon. Donc c'est plutôt
ça que je dis aujourd'hui. Euh je mais
je encore une fois je suis pas
grand-chose, je peux pas conseiller,
j'ai pas des parcours clés en main.
Chacun doit réfléchir à ça en tout cas.
Vous êtes fait vous êtes fait quand même
bien ravager comme
auteur, non ?
Euh oui, absolum.
Vous en gardez une ranqueur ou pas ? Non
non parce je m'attendais un peu pour
tout vous dire on écrit un bouquin sur
l'insécurité, on s'attend pas à voir que
des potes mais je pensais pas déjà que
le livre c'est
catastrophique l'insécurité vraiment.
Ah bah 1000 agressions gratuites par
jour officiellement recensé c'est
énorme. Le nombre de de de Françaises
violé tous les jours aujourd'hui c'était
200 à l'époque de la France Orange
mécanique. Ce nombre a cessé d'augmenter
et d'ailleurs on a fait on l'a fait on a
on a tout fait pour le faire disparaître
des statistiques. Il est extrêmement
élevé. Il a jamais été aussi élevé. Donc
c'est vraiment enfin à la viol c'est des
viols par des immigrés, par la famille,
par les voisins. Il y a de tout. Il y a
il y a les viols les fameux viols
familiaux conjugaux qui représentent une
part de ces viols, une part minoritaire
mais une part importante quand même. Et
il y a les viols. Alors souvent euh
l'individu connu hein qui est pas
forcément de la famille mais que voilà
par euh
par voilà circonstan
se retrouve en position de commettre le
délit.
Euh il y a aussi des viols par des
inconnus parfaits, par des ce qu'on a
les prédateurs, hein. Ça existe
objectivement et le nombre enfin c'est
l'ampleur de ce phénomène est vraiment
très importante. Et je enfin moi ça m'a
un peu sié que sur le plateau de Ruquier
de dire il y a 200 femmes violées en
jour par jour en France et on vous
répond mais vous êtes raciste. Et
finalement 5 ans après, tout le monde
dit "Effectivement les violences faites
aux femmes c'est très préoccupant mais
n'empêche on a perdu 5 ans et ça fait 5
ans de victimes de plus et on refuse
enfin de se de se pencher sur le
problème de se dire "Mais attendez 1 %
des violeurs condamnés
quand même c'est un problème."
Vous les tenez pour responsable ? Ah
bah, ils ont une part de responsabilité,
c'est clair. C'est c'est pas eux qui ont
commis le le le délit, mais leur devoir,
la déontologie journalistique stipule
que normalement, on doit transmettre les
informations euh selon des critères
impartiaux et de qualité neutre. C'est
une charte Dominique,
je connais pas par cœur toutes les
chartes, mais
j'ai lu suffisamment. Je honnêtement là,
je pourrais pas vous citer de tête quoi
que ce soit là-dessus. Je
Ça parle de quoi ? Ça sert à quoi ?
C'est pour qui ? Ah je Alors là et si ne
me demandez pas le nombre exact de
sous-marins nucléaire français parce que
je peux le prix de la baguette par
contre je le connais.
C'est les les droits et devoirs du
journalisme signés par beaucoup de pays.
Ah mais alors moi je vous dis
l'équivalent du serment d'Hippocrate
j'ai vu passer quantité de de de papiers
sur la déontologie qui était très beau,
vibrant et cetera, sur le le ce qu'il
fallait faire quand on était journaliste
et c'est exactement ce que mes collègues
ne faisaient pas. Donc enfin ça pose un
problème et manifestement voilà le
problème il ils font ils sont une partie
du problème. C'est clair. Comment vous
voyez l'avenir de l'investigation ?
L'investigation elle souffre beaucoup du
fait que aussi le journaliste est un est
un faiseur de copie aujourd'hui hein.
Vous avez n'importe quel truc dépêche
qui va tomber de la FP et la plus grosse
part du boulot des journalistes consiste
à la reproduire à peu près à l'identique
sans vérifier quoi que ce soit. euh sans
vérifier les sources, enfin sans faire
le travail qui va avec. En fait,
aujourd'hui, ils sont là pour remplir du
contenu. Euh en fait, on ajoute des
articles à des à des à des à des
prospects publicitaires. Le journalisme,
c'est quasiment ça aujourd'hui. Donc
l'investigation qui coûte cher, demande
beaucoup d'argent, ténacité et cetera,
elle existe de moins en moins. Donc
évidemment, c'est déplorable mais c'est
la la la standardisation logique du
métier sur l'infontainement, le
divertissement.
Publir reportage.
Le publi reportage. Ouais.
Vous avez un un avis sur Combin ?
Non, j'ai pas j'ai non, j'ai pas
brut.
J'ai Non, j'ai pas d'avis. Euh j'avoue
que je regarde très assez peu. J'ai vu
dû voir passer quelques quelques vidéos
comme ça.
Votre votre média préféré, c'est quoi ?
Euh
c'est monsieur moyen, je dirais. C'est
J'ai pas de J'ai pas de référentiel où
tous les jours je me dis j'ai un média.
Je alors je lis pas mal, je lis les
médias justement. euh tous les grands
médias mainstream justement pour déser
détecter un peu la manière de présenter
les choses euh de l enfin c'est un peu
comme les contrats vers eux hein c'est
vous avez un titre et cetera, vous avez
un chapeau qui dit déjà un truc un peu
différent le développement est encore
sensiblement différent et la conclusion
en tout petit c'est que 95 % des
lecteurs ne liront pas et l'information
essentielle du papier et cette manière
de hiérarchiser l'information
m'intéresse de par la technique qu'elle
implique des techniques de psy
psychologie de base de manipulation de
l'information et donc je m'intéresse à
la presse en général. En fait,
vous avez dit sur une web TV euh un peu
catau de droite qui s'appelle je crois
TV Liberté.
TV Liberté
que que les migrants qui venaient chez
nous c'était c'était pas les plus futés,
pas les plus brillants, pas les plus
C'est absolument vrai. C'est pas moi qui
le dit hein, c'est Lined Linec le niveau
de qualification des migrants, le niveau
moyen de qualification des migrants
français, il est très bas. C'est les
plus débrouillards qui viennent, c'est
ceux qui ont le plus la rage, qui ont
sorti
qui sont qui ont la responsabilité tout
un village derrière eux. C'est
objectivement euh des individus qui sont
au-dessus de la moyenne du pays d'où ils
viennent parce que il faut beaucoup
d'argent pour faire la traversée la
plupart du temps même pour payer les
passeurs. Payer les passeurs, je crois
que ça allait de 2000 à 8000 € quelque
chose comme ça en moyenne. Donc fournir
2000 € quand on vient d'Afrique
sub-saharienne, c'est vraiment énorme.
Donc c'est clair que les individus qui
font le voyage ne sont pas du tout ils
sont pas représentatifs de leur propre
pays mais pour autant ils sont quand
même loin des standards de l'OCDE.
Ça c'est c'est un fait quoi. Et on le
constate sur plusieurs générations.
C'est c'est pas juste les immigrés, les
descendants d'immigrés aussi hein.
D'après toutes les études réalisées par
le CDE, que ce soit au niveau scolaire,
en terme de compéten il tirent pas le
niveau vers le haut. Ça c'est un fait.
C'est comme ça.
Est-ce que vous avez des bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Des bouquins à conseiller. Moi, je suis
très client de tout ce qui est
psychologie évolutive,
rat de Lawrence, Dawkins, et cetera.
Tout le
pour le coup, ça n'a rien à voir avec le
comment
vous connaissez le réflexe de Lawrence ?
Le réflexe de Lawrence ? Euh alors je
sais pas si on parle du même Lawrence.
Coron Conrad Lawrence.
Vous connaissez le réflexe de Lawrence ?
Je sais pas. Dites-moi.
La mémoire.
Je
vous savez quand un animal fait sa
toilette pour montrer sa soumission.
Non
là comme ça je vous dis enfin pourtant
j'ai lu tous ces bouquins mais ce ce
truc précis ne m'a pas
enfin je me suis beaucoup intéressé à
ces ces recherches sur l'agression enfin
leologie
sur l'agression quand il y a bon vous
avez peut-être pas bien lu. Non mais
enfin ça a pu vous c'est c'est je l je
lis beaucoup de trucs et je prétends pas
retenir absolument tout comme ça et vous
restituer tout c'est l'esprit de
l'escalier he je vais sortir tout à
l'heure je vais dire mais oui c'est ça
mais je pourrais pas revenir pour vous
le dire mais
Conrade Lawrence quoi d'autre
Cor Laence
moi enfin après je sais pas les auteurs
classiques, il faut relire tous les
classiques français évidemment la
Fontaine au premier rang de tous Paul
Valérie plus récemment
beaucoup de choses à nous apprendre
Ce sont pas des lectures qui sont en
rapport avec les thèmes que je que je
traite hein, mais enfin c'est c'est les
lectures que je conseille.
Donc tout ce qui est psychologie
évolutive, vous avez aujourd'hui vous
avez Steven Pinker par exemple qui
publie pas mal de bouquins, enfin tous
ces courants là. Moi, j'aime bien aussi
les auteurs un peu libertaires. Charles
Muret par exemple aux États-Unis, très
intéressant des sujets qu'on peut pas
enfin qu'on trouve pas du tout en
France. La France est complètement
réticente à toutes ces notions-là et
totalement axé sur la sociologie euh et
refuse de voir ce qui se passe ailleurs
en fait dans les pays anglo-saxons
notamment.
Quelque chose à rajouter ?
Non.
Laurent Bertone, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]